استدعت الخارجيه الباكستانيه سفيرها من
ايران على خلفيه قصف طهران لاراضي
باكستانيه وحملت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الباكستانيه ممتاز زهره بلوش حملت ايران
مسؤوليه عواقب بما قامت به واكدت ان
بلادها تحتفظ بحقها في
الرد ان الانتهاك غير المبرر الذي حدث
الليله الماضيه لسياده باكستان من قبل
ايران يعد انتهاكا للقانون الدولي وميثاق
الامم المتحده وهذا العمل غير القانوني
غير مقبول على الاطلاق وباكستان تحتفظ بحق
الرد على هذا العمل ومسؤوليه عواقبه ستقع
على عاتق ايران بشكل مباشر وقد ابلغنا
ايران بقرارنا سحب سفيرنا من طهران وبان
السفير الايراني لدى باكستان والذي يزور
ايران حاليا لن يعود في الوقت الحالي وقد
قررنا كذلك تعليق جميع الزيارات واللقاءات
رافيعه المستوى التي كان مخططا لها وتلك
القائمه حاليا بين باكستان وايران وحتى
للايام المقبله من امام وزاره الخارجيه في
اسلام اباد مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن
مطر ومن طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
القادر فايز ونبدا معك عبد القادر وهذه
التصريحات لوزير الخارجيه الايراني الذي
اكد فيها بالفعل
استهداف او قصف في داخل باكستان وفي داخل
العراق م حجج التي ساقها وتسوقها تهران
لقصف بلدين جارين يفترض ان العلاقات معهما
طيبه هي مفاضله حقيقه زين ما بين الامن
والسياسي الواضح تماما بان هناك تقدم
للمعطي الامني في العقليه ربما
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه في السياق الحالي
الاقليمي على المعطى السياسي بمعنى ان
ايران تدرك بان هناك تغييرات كبرى حقيقه
في الاقليم وهناك ربما تغيير
في العقليه التي تحكم الامن الاقليمي تشعر
بتهديدات تشعر بقلق الاراضي التي ذكرتها
سواء في العراق او حتى في سوريا كان واضح
بان ايران لماذا فعلت ذلك وتحدثنا عن ذلك
سابقا حقيقه ولكن الموضوع الباكستاني
مختلف حقيقه زيد نحن نتحدث عن جار كبير
وازم بالمعنى الاقليمي وبالمعنى الدولي
يران لذلك هذا المعطى ما جرى يمكن ان اقول
بان هناك ملاحظتين اثنتين هامتان حقيقه
الملاحظه الاولى بان ايران حتى الان الحرس
الثوري الايراني حتى الان وانا اتحدث الان
لم يصدر اي بيان عسكري يقول انه ضرب
الاراضي الباكستانيه مع ان وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه قالت ذلك صراحه وبات معروف بانه
فعل ذلك وهذا بخلاف ما فعله حقيقه في
العراق وسوريا حتى الان كذلك لا يوجد
تعليق ايراني رسمي لا من الخارجيه ولا من
غيرها على الخطوات التي تحدثت عنها
باكستان بالمعطي السياسي ماذا يعني ذلك
حقيقه زيني ذلك يعني على الاقل في التحليل
ربما القائم على بعض المعلومات الغير
رسميه بان ايران لا تريد ان تتبنى بيانا
عسكريا رسميا من الحرس الثوري بادبيان
سياسيه ربما
ولغه معينه قد تكون مستفزه لباكستان في
بعدين البعد الاول ديني والبعد الثاني
سياسي له علاقه بالسياده الوطنيه المعطى
الثاني بان يبدو بان هناك من يسعى الى فتح
الابواب الخلفيه للتعاطي مع باكستان في
هذه المرحله ولا يريد ان يذهب باتجاه
التصعيد بمعنى انه يمكن الغزل في السياسه
لتحييد المعطى الامني ولكن ماذا فعل الحرس
الثوري تقول وسائل الاعلام هنا رسميا
بانها ضربت جيش العدل الموجود في الاراضي
الباكستانيه المصنف ايرانيا بانه منظمه
ارهابيه سابقا قام جيش العدل بعمليات داخل
الاراضي الايرانيه بشكل واضح ادت الى
ضحايا على مدى سنوات طويله العمليه
الاخيره التي تقول ايران بان جيش العدل
انطلاقا من الاراضي الباكستانيه له علاقه
بها هي عمليه راسك والهجوم على احد مقرات
الشرطه في هذه المنطقه الواقعه في جنوب
شرق البلاد ولكن اخيرا زين يمكن ان نقول
بانه من المتوقع ان نسمع شيء ما من ايران
في السياسه لماذا لان العلاقه بين باكستان
وايران مهمه جدا معقده جدا بالمعنى
الثنائي وبالمعنى الاقليمي ولها اهميه
خاصه على المستوى الدولي كذلك ط عبد
الرحمن مطر من اسلام باد طبعا الخارجيه
الباكستانيه استدعت السفير سفيرها من
ايران لكن المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه زهره
ممتاز زهره بلوش قالت ان باكستان تحتفظ
بحقها في
الرد هذا تطور كيف يعني يتابع في كيف
تتعامل معه باكستان الرسميه وايضا من حيث
وسائل الاعلام و الناس ماذا يقولون
عنه طبعا الواضح ان باكستان حسمت موقفها
بشان الهجوم الذي تعرضت له مساء امس وقالت
بان مسؤوليه هذا الهجوم والعواقب المتوقعه
عليه تقع بالكامل على عاتق الجانب
الايراني وقالت بانها تحتفظ بحق الرد
وقالت ايضا بان هذا الخرق لهذه للسياده
الباكستانيه سيكون له بالتاكيد رد وربما
رد كبير حسب المتوقع بحسب الكثير من
المصادر هنا الخطوه الاوليه التي تم
اتخاذها وسحب السفير الباكستاني من ايران
والقول للحكومه الايرانيه بان سفيره ايران
لدى باكستان الموجود حاليا في اجازه في
طهران لن يعود الى باكستان على الاقل في
هذه المرحله اضافه الى ذلك الغاء كل
اللقاءات الثنائيه سواء المستمره حاليا او
المتوقع القيام بها خلال الايام المقبله
اذا باكستان موقفها واضح وصريح فيما يتعلق
بالهجوم الذي تعرضت له بالامس والذي قالت
بانه غير مبرر وانه ايضا غير قانوني وان
ان انه يعتبر خرق للميثاق الامم المتحده
نتوقع ربما خلال الفتره المقبله رد اكثر
من باكستان لا سما وان ايران على ما يبدو
حرقت سفنها مع الجانب الباكستاني بهذا
الهجوم غير المبرر كما تقول الحكومه
الباكستانيه والذي بالتاكيد ستكون له
الكثير من العواقب خلال الايام القليله
المقبله الخطوه التي اتخذت اليوم هي خطوه
اولى هي خطوه دبلوماسيه او سياسيه في
المقام الاول لكن من غير المستبعد ان يكون
لها هناك ان يكون هناك العديد من الخطوات
لا سيما وان باكستان لا تعترف ابدا بوجود
ما يسمى بجيش العدل داخل الاراضي
الباكستانيه و بالتاكيد الحكومه
الباكستانيه تنظر الى كل ما تقوله ايران
على انه غير واقعي وغير منطقي وانه كان
لابد من ان يتم التواصل معها مسبقا في هذا
السياق لا سما وان قنوات الاتصال كانت
دائما مفتوحه مع ايران لكن على ما يبدو ان
الجانب الايراني اتخذ خطوه ستكون له عواقب
بحسب ما قال
الباكستانيون شكرا جزيلا لك من طهران مدير
مكتب الجزيره عبد القادر فاز ومن اسلام
ابد طبعا نشكر مدير مكب الجزيره عبد
الرحمن
مطر